السلام عليكم واهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
المقابله الخاصه التي نجريها مع عبد الله
باتيليا المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا
سيداتيلي اهلا بك وشكرا على قبولك الحديث
معنا
سيداتي
[موسيقى]
وكذلك كل من يتابع السيد
مع كل الاطراف الليبيه على خطه او على
مبادره كنتم وضعتموها تنتهي باجراء
انتخابات في نهايه هذا العام ما الذي تحقق
الى غايه الان في هذا المسار او الطريق
الانتخابات وهل بالفعل يمكن اجراء
الانتخابات في الموعد المحدد من قبلكم
نامل بان الانتخابات سوف تجرى في هذا
العام
ظروف مواتيه وانا اشعر انه يمكن ان نجري
هذه الانتخابات التي تاخرت كثيرا منذ عام
وجهت ليبيا
مرحله انتقاليه تسمت بمؤسسات انتقاليه
واعتقد انه قد حان الوقت بالنسبه للشعب
الليبي ليكون له مؤسسات شرعيه هي مسؤوله
امام الشعب الليبي
والليبيون يرغبون في
كل لديهم مؤسسات مستدامه بوسعها ان تهتم
بتلبيه
احتياجاتهم
وكذلك توفير خدمات التعليم والصحه وكذلك
توفر اداره اقتصاديه سليمه في البلاد
وكذلك مؤسسات يمكن لها ان توفر العمليه
السلميه تجلب السلم او الامن الى ليبيا
وهذا امر قد طال امده ولذلك فانني
ضمن تفويض الممنوح لي
بالاجرية اتصالات مع كافه الاطراف الليبيه
لان الانتخابات هي
تعني المن سيقود البلاد
والانتخابات تمثل لحظه تاريخيه بالنسبه
للمواطنين حتى يمكن لهم ان يسالوا او
يسائل قادتهم وهذه فرصه للقاده الذين
يرغبون في قياده البلاد ان يتواصلوا مع
المواطنين
ويناقشوا معهم كل ما لديهم من افكار ورؤى
بالنسبه لليبيا وهذا هو سبيل الكفيل بجلب
الاستقرار وتنميه
ليبيا ولذلك عملت على القيام بذلك منذ
تعيين في شهر اكتوبر في هذا المنصب
وليتم التعبير عن هذه الاراء من خلال
جهود تتذكرين انه من عام 2011
تم تسجيل اعداد كبيره من الناخبين ما يقرب
من ثلاثه ملايين الناخب تم تسجيلهم
للمشاركه في الانتخابات وهذا دليل عن
الرغبه رغبه الليبيين لتعبير عن رؤاهم
بشان من سيقود بلادهم وبناء عليه فهذا
تحديدا
نسعى للقيام به
والمؤسسات الحاليه في ليبيا ينتظر منها ان
تنجز ما يريده
الليبيون وقد عملنا على اساس القاعده
الدستوريه وكذلك القانون الانتخابي لاكثر
من اربع سنوات واعتقد انه قد حان الوقت
لاستكمال هذه
المناقشات تمهيد لاجراء او ليكون هناك
قانون انتخابي يسمح باجراء هذه الانتخابات
ولكن
هل بالفعل يمكن اجراء
نهايه العام في الفتره المحدده من قبلكم
نعلم بان الاطار القانوني ليس واضح الى
غايه الان مع كل عمل سته زائد سته معكم
فهل الموعد يمكن ان يمدد ام انكم مصرون
على فكره نهايه السنه لاجراء انتخابات
نيابيه او رئاسيه كذلك في ليبيا
اذا كانت هناك نوايا حسنه وكذلك التزام
حقيقي
لتكون هناك ليبيا مستقره وكذلك لايجاد
الظروف التي تسمح باجراء الانتخابات فان
هذه الانتخابات سوف تجرى
صراحه ارى ان القضايا التي هي على المحك
واضحه وهي كانت على الطاوله منذ اكثر من
عام
والان تم مناقشه هذه القضايا لاكثر من
سنتين
واذا كان هناك
نيه حسنه وكذلك التزام سياسي واخلاقي
حقيقي وكذلك اذا ما اتخذ القرار
بالاستجابه لنداء الشعبي الليبي فلا ارى
اي سبب يمنع عقده هذه الانتخابات وطبعا
الانتخابات لا تقتصر على القانون
الانتخابي
ذلك هي لا تقتصر على الاتفاقات السياسيه
كما انها لا تخص فقط القاعده الدستوريه
وانما تعني اشراك الشعب الليبي وكذلك كافه
الاطراف ذات العلاقه ولذلك قلت بانه ينبغي
علينا اشراك كافه اصحاب المصلحه بما في
ذلك على سبيل المثال القاده الامنيين
واللجنه العسكريه خمسه زائد واحد طرحت
مقترحا لاشراك ليس المؤسسات العسكريه فحسب
ولكن كذلك القاده الامنيين في البلاد ايضا
في الشهور والاسابيع الماضيه فان المسار
الامني قد اتسم باكتساب الكثير من الزخم
والقاده العسكريون وكذلك الامنيون يشاركون
في ذلك وقد اتفقوا على
هنا
مدونه الشرف
لتامين العمليه الانتخابيه وبالتالي هذه
خطوه مهمه جدا
لاجراء الانتخابات والقاده السياسيون
الذين نتواصل معهم هنا في ليبيا هم ايزن
يريدون اجراء هذه الانتخابات وهذا ينطبقوا
على الجماعات الشباب والنساء وكذلك
الاعيان في ربوع ليبيا وبشكل عام هناك
طبعا رغبه لدى الشعب الليبي بعمته لاجراء
الانتخابات هم يريدون قياده مسؤوله وكذلك
يريدون قادم بوسعهم ان يديروا بطريقه
ملائمه شؤون البلاد اذا يوجد هذه الروح
وكذلك هذا الزخم الذي تمخد اسابيع وشهور
من المناقشات مما يسمح باجراء الانتخابات
هذا العام انتم تعملون مع كل الاطراف
الليبيه على الارض
وتعرفون جيدا هذه الاجسام الليبيه على
الساحه اليوم هل تعتقدون فعلا بان هذه
الشخصيات وهذه الاجسام ترغب في رجاء
انتخابات في ليبيا
في هذه السنه انا ادعوهم
لا اعلم ما يدور في اذهانهم ولكن الحقائق
تدل عن نفسها ولكن اليوم الشعب الليبي
يرغب في اجراء الانتخابات وفي هذه هي
اللحظه التاريخيه سوف يتم تسجيل مواقف
كافه القاده فيما اذا كانوا يرغبون في
الاستجابه لهذا النداء
نداء الشعب الليبي ام لا
وطبعا في اوقات الازمه هذه من الاهميه
بمكان للقاده الليبيين ان يستجيبوا لهذا
النداء الندائي شعبهم
وان
يتجاوز
المصالح الشخصيه
ويتجاوز ايضا المصالح
الفئويه وينظر الى مستقبل ليبيا ينظر الى
الشباب الذين يرغبون في مستقبل اكثر
اشراقا من ليبيا لديها موارد هائله بوسعها
ان تلبي احتياجات الشباب فيما يخص
بالتعليم والرعايه الصحيه والبنيه التحتيه
ان الحرب قد دمرت البنى تحتيه في ليبيا
وهي لم يتم اعاده اعمارها وقد حان الوقت
الان
لترحي الاعتبارات الاخرى جانبا والنظر الى
مستقبل ليبيا ولذلك فهذه مساله اخلاقيه
وسياسيه وهذه هذا واجب ملقى على كاهل
الليبيين هذه ليست مساله المجتمع الدولي
وكذلك بعثه الامم المتحده لاعاده اعمار
ليبيا وايجابي او او بناء المصالحه
الليبيه هذا الامر يعود القاده الليبيين
الذين عليهم التكفل بواجبهم للقيام بذلك
كنت قلت ان الاجسام التشريعيه منتهيه
الولايات تعرض ليبيا للخطر
من تقصدون تحديدا بهذه الاجسام المنتهيه
الشرعيه
طبعا الجميع يدرك ان
المجلسين عندما تم انشاؤهما وقد تم طبعا
انشاء المجلس
المجلس الاعلى للدوله منذ عام 2012 وكذلك
مجلس النواب وبالتالي فان
ولايه هذين المجلسين قد انتهت وبالتالي من
المهم حتى بالنسبه لهذين المجلسين كضامنين
لاستقرار البلاد ان يدعى على الطاوله
او المهام التي اوكلت لهما وان يكون هناك
عقد جديد مع شعبي الليبي والانتخابات هي
ان
الشخص فتره ولايته وبعد ذلك يسمح بتجديد
هذه الولايه انها قضيه اخلاقيه وكذلك هي
مساله سياسيه او مساله
الصدق والتزام وهذا ما يريده الشعب الليبي
على غرار كافه شعوب العالم في اطار حديث
عن الانتخابات وعن جو السياسي حينها هل
تعتقدون انه يمكن اجراء انتخابات في ظل
حكومتين في البلاد ام يجب توحيد السلطه
التنفيذيه توحيد الحكومه
بالنسبه للمساله المتعلقه بسلطه التنفيذيه
فهي تتعلق ايضا بالاراده السياسيه للقاده
ليبيين من الاهميه بمكان التوحيد السلطه
التنفيذيه وشعب وليبيا يرغب في ان يحكمه
سلطه تنفيذيه واحده ان يتم توحيد هذه
السلطه التنفيذيه
من خلال
المؤسسات التمثيليه مثل المجلس النواب
والمجلس الاعلى
والمجلس الدوله ومن المهم ان يكون هناك
ايضا مؤسسات عسكريه موحده يجب ان يكون
ايضا بنك مركزي ليبي واحد هذه كلها قضايا
هي عباره عن قضايا تتسبب بانقسام داخل
ليبيا وفي ظل هذه المؤسسات المنقسمه لا
يمكن ايجاد ظروف تسمح بتحقيق الازدهار في
ليبيا والشعب الليبي قد سئم من انقسام هذه
المؤسسات وهم سئموا ايضا من وضع
يواجهون فيه
مخاطر بشان السياده الوطنيه ووحده الاراضي
الليبيه وهذه المخاطر سوف تزداد في ظل هذه
الاوضاع الانتقاليه وعلاوه على ذلك فيمكن
او ندعو ان لا يحدث ذلك ندعو الله العلي
القدير الا يحدث هذا لكن البلاد سوف تتفتت
وتنقسم
وبالتالي فان هذا الوضع سوف يكون على حساب
الشعبي الليبي
وكلما سافرت هناك صوت وحيد اسمعه من
الليبين هم يرغبون من بقاء بلادهم موحده
وان تستفيد من الموارد الموجوده فيها يتم
تطوير البلاد لمصلحه مستقبل الاطفال
والنساء يريدن وحده الاراضي الليبيه وهذا
ينطبق على الشباب
الذين يدعون
المؤسسات العسكريه التي عبرت عن التزامها
بوحده البلاد ان يتوحدوا وان يصونوا ايضا
الاراضي الليبيه وحداتها والقاده الامنيون
الذين يجرون هذا الحوار في هذه الاثنى
فيما بينهم وهناك اشخاص اخرون
نوايا حسنه ومسؤولون في البلاد يرغبون
تحقيق هذه الوحده وسبب الوحيد والامثل
لتحقيق ذلك هو من خلال اجراء الانتخابات
ووجود مؤسسات تحظى بالاعتراف كتعبير
لاراده الشعبيه الليبي من خلال صناديق
الاقتراع في اطار الاخبار التي تصلنا
تباعا من ليبيا اخر التطورات تشير الى ان
فتح بشغه وجه كتابا لمجلس النواب الليبي
لتفويض القطراني بمهامه وصلاحيته لا نعلم
لغايه الان ما تفاصيل هذا القرار ولكن هل
لديكم اي تعليق
على هذه التطورات
هذا تطور سمعته للتو ونحن نراقب الوضع عن
كسب وعندما يحين الوقت سوف نجري تقييم
لهذا اتطور ولكن اذكر فيما يخصني انا انا
اجتمعت مع كافه الاطراف ذات المصلحه في
ليبيا بمن فيهم حكومه
بشاغه وكذلك
مؤسساتنا
قبل يومين فقط
عقدته اجتماع مع رئيس الحكومه الدبيبه
وبالنسبه لنا من المهم نحن كبعثت الامم
المتحده ووفقا لتفويض الممنوح لنا ان ندعو
كافه الليبيين كما اسلفت ندعوهم للتوحد
وتوحيد صفوفهم وتوصل الى حلول وسط لتوحيد
بلادهم على مستوى كافه المؤس وان ينظروا
بجديه في سلوكي سبيل الانتخابات وانا
اتابع هذه التطورات وسوف نقيمها في حينها
ولكن ما هو اكثر اهميه الان هو ان كافه
القاده الليبيين عليهم ان يطلعوا بادوارهم
بجديه وان يعملوا ايضا باتجاه اجراء
الانتخابات
ويوحد البلاد ويجعل ليبيا بلدا عظيما
وان يعيدوا ليبيا لتقف على قدميها كبلاد
وكجهه فاعله في هذا الاقليم
وليس فقط على سواحد البحر الابيض المتوسط
ولكن في القاره الافريقيه كجهه فاديه
فاعله من اجل السلام والاستقرار وتنميه
هذه مساله غايه في الاهميه الان وهذا ما
نامله بالنسبه لليبيا وهذا ايضا ما يطلبه
الليبيون
البرلمان الليبي يحجب الثقه عن برشاغه
ويتحدث الان عن تحقيق سيجريه هذا ايضا
تطور اخر في المسار السياسي لا اعلم الى
اي درجه بالامكان الحديث عنه باعتبار ان
التطورات عاجله
ومدى تاثير هذا التطور على المسار الذي
يقوم به
تقومون به
وحده السلطه التنفيذيه
تكون اداه سوف تسرع اجراء الانتخابات ولا
تعيقها على العكس من ذلك
واعتقد ان ذلك سيكون فرصه للجانبين
حتى يتم توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه والمؤسسات
الليبيه هذا ما ندعو اليه
نعلم جميعا بان واحده من ابرز العقبات
امام اجراء الانتخابات في ليبيا وشروط
الترشح كذلك ما المقاربه الامميه المتعلقه
بشروط الترشح هل من المفترض او من الضروري
ان يسمح للعسكريين ولوجوه النظام السابق
بان يترشحوا للرئاسيات ونقصد هنا بالتاكيد
خليفه حفتر سيف الاسلام القذافي وغيرهم من
الشخصيات بالتاكيد
ادركوا ان تمت قضايا جدليه بما في ذلك
معايير الترشح للانتخابات
ولكن فيما يخص بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم
في ليبيا
الانتخابات حتى تكون
ممثله لاراده الشعب الليبي ومن اجل توصل
الى استقرار بفضل هذه الانتخابات هذه
الانتخابات يجب ان لا تستثني احدا وقد
اظهر التاريخ وكذلك اظهرت التجارب في ربوع
العالم انه عندما يتم استثناء فئات من
المجتمع او افراد من الانتخابات
على اساس
ينظر اليه على انه يحظى
بالتوافق هذا
او يزيد اعطينا ما نريد ان نتفاداهن هو
الانتخابات المشكك فيها
وحتى لا يتم رفض نتائج الانتخابات وهذا
يتطلب بطبيعه الحال اشراك كافه
المترشحين طبعا هناك قضايا خلافيه لكن هذه
القضايا الخلافيه يمكن مناقشتها بطريقه
منفتحه لان ليبيا بحاجه
لتوحيد كافه ابنائها وبناتها ليكون ذلك
بدايه من اجل المصالحه الوطنيه حتى يتم
التوصل الى توافق للاراء بشان القضايا
الخلافيه والتوافق التوافق الاراء يتعلق
بمستقبل هذا البلاد ففي ظل انعدام التوافق
لا يمكن ان نتجاوز الازمه الراهنه وقد
اثبتت التجارب ذلك في كل الاماكن
الشعوب التي واجهت حروب خطيره عندما تنتهي
هذه الحروب بتوافق للاراء هذا يكون في
مصلحه البلاد والان من المهم بالنسبه
ليبيين ان نتوصل لذلك
وهذا ما يتم التعبير عنه على المستوى
الشعبي طبعا جراحه الحروب موجوده في كافه
المناطق ولاقاليم والاسر الليبيه هناك
اشخاص فقط واحبائهم
وهناك من فقدوا ارواحهم طبعا وحدث الكثير
من الدمار في كثير في جميع المناطق
الليبيه على مدى الاثني عشر عام من
الماضيه علينا
صفحه الجراح هذه الصفحه الكراهيه ونفتح
صفحه مصالحه جديده صفحه جديده مبنيه على
توافق الاراء لاعاده بناء البلاد بمشاركته
كافه المواطنين وان يتم تطلع نحو مستقبل
مشرق لليبيا ليبيا ليبيا التفاعل
الاخوه والاخوات ليبيا التفاعل السلمي
من
طرابلس الى
المناطق الليبيه هذا ما يريده الليبيون
هذا لا يقتصر على ليبيا التي
شهدت هذا النوع من الازمات عبر تاريخها
وهذه الحروب ايضا ولكن حان الوقت الان ان
يتم تجاوز هذه المرحله وهذا لن يتاتى الا
اذا تم التوصل الى حلول وس بين القاده
والواقع انه ضمن الشعب الليبي هناك رغبه
حقيقيه في الحلول الوسط وبالتالي على
القاده الليبيين ان يلتقوا الى هذه
المسؤوليات وكذلك يساعد الليبيين على
البحث على الحلول الوسط ولذلك
ناشدت لجنه سته زائد سته وكذلك قاده
المجلس الاعلى او مجلس الدوله ومجلس
النواب ان يتحدوا لاخراج البلد من هذا
المستنقع انها لحظه تاريخيه
والزخم يسمح بتحقيق ذلك ولو تحقق هذا
الامر اعتقد انه يمكن انجاز الكثير نعم
الى السودان المجاور
هناك من يعتقد في ليبيا بان هذه الازمه
السودانيه هذا الاقتتال بين السودانيين
يؤثر على داخل الليبي خاصه في ملف اخراج
المرتزقه من الدول الافريقيه
هل تعتقدون بان الازمه السودانيه ستؤثر
فعلا على ليبيا وعلى مساء اخراج المرتزقه
من ليبيا
اذكر بان في شهر مارس الماضي في نهايه شهر
مارس قمت بزياره الى السودان وكذلك الى
تشاد والى النيجر
[موسيقى]
برنامج
انسحاب
المقاتلين اجانب والمرتزقه وتواصلت مع
القاده السودانيين على كافه المستويات
وكذلك مع قاده تشاد والنيجر كل هؤلاء
القاده عبروا عن رغبتهم للعمل دون هود
حقيقه
لتحقيق هذا المطلب وهذه الحدود بين هذه
البلدان سوف تكون فضاء
لسلامي والاستقرار والتنميه والتعاون
الاخوي
ونحن
كانت لدينا امال كبيره بنهايه
مارس وبدايه شهر ابريل بهذا الشان المؤسف
ان الازمه في السودان
ففجرت ونحن نامل حقا وندعو ان يتم تسويه
هذه الازمه ولدينا امال كبيره بشان
المحادثات الجاريه حاليا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ونعمل ان يتمكن شعب السوداني وقدته من طي
صفحته الصراع هذه والان يجب ان اقول
انها ثم تداعيات محدوده
فيما يخص الحدود بين السودان وليبيا
ولكن نامل ان الازمه فيها السودان سوف لن
تمتد
الى كل هذه البلدان لانه لو تنظرين الى
حاله الحدود فان الامر سيكون خطيرا
ان يتفرج الانسان عما يحدث يكون امرا
خطيرا ايضا ولذلك ادعو كفه القدم الليبيين
للعمل في هذا الاطار من اجل السلمي
والاستقرار ومن المهم ايضا بالنسبه
لكافه هذه البلدان ان تدعم هذه المحادثات
في اطار نسميه
بلجنه الاتصالات بين اللجنه خمسه زائد
خمسه العسكريه في ليبيا وكذلك نظرائهم في
السودان ونيجر وتشاد ويحدون الامل
بان الوقت سوف يحين لذلك هو لجنه التنسيق
لجان التنسيق سوف تعمل بشكل وثيق فيما
بينها من اجل تفادي امتداد
الصراع وتصاعده
طبعا
لو تساعد هذا الصراع سيكون طبعا له
تداعيته سلبيه على ليبيا خاصه فيما يتعلق
بانسحاب المرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب
ليبيا لان ذلك سوف يتم بطريقه متسقه كما
نعمل ان لا يؤثر ذلك ايضا على استقرار
البلدان الاخرى اذن هناك مجال للتعاون
بهذا الصدد وكما تلاحظين ما يحدث اليوم في
السودان هو عباره عن ناقوس خطر بالنسبه
الليبيين بالنسبه لهم ان ينظروا الى الوضع
الذي اذا كان فيه المرحله الانتقاليه لا
تسوى بطريقه سلميه
في اطار تقديم تنازلات من قبل القاده واذا
لم يتم التوصل الى حلول وسط فان السيره
يمكن ان يشهدوا حالتها تصعيد فعلى
الليبيين ان ينظروا الى السودان كدرس يجب
ان نستخلص عليهم ان يذهبوا نحو الاتجاه
الانتخابات على اساس
التنازلات
واذا استمر التصعيد في ليبيا واذا لم يتم
التوصل الى حل وسط فان الترتيبات
الانتقاليه اذا ما استمرت فهذا سيؤدي الى
صراع اكبر
بكبير وله تداعيات مدمره اكثر بكثير ففي
ليبيا لن تقتصر الامر على طرفين متحاربين
وانما عدد من المتحاربين في الوقت ذاته
وبالتالي ادعو كافه الليبيين القاده مره
اخرى ان يغتنموا هذه الفرصه وينظر اليها
على انها لحظه فريده من نوعها لتتاح
بلادهم لتخرج من هذا الوضع الصعب
لاعاده بناء ليبيا ليبيا المستقبل
ليبيا يطمح اليها المواطنون الليبيون بكل
شرعيه هناك بعض وسائل الاعلام الغربيه
التي تتحدث عن تورط جهات ليبيه في الازمه
السودانيه عن ارسال هذه الجهات ارسال
مساعدات لطرف سوداني في هذا الاقتتال هل
لديكم معلومات تؤكد هذا التورط او تنفيه
نحن نراقب عن كسب الوضع على الحدود
كما تعلمين
فريق الامم المتحده
وفرق المتحده في البلدان
المجاوره ليس لدينا جميعا اي دليل
عم تفضلتي به ولكن كما قلت نحن نراقب نرصد
الاوضاعا كسب فانه ليس من مصلحه اي طرف
ليبي
التدخل في الازمه في السودان يجب ان يعمل
الجميع على المساعده
على المساعده مساعده
الفرقاء السودانيين
اصحاب المصلحه السودانيين لدعم المحادثات
الجاريه من اجل تحقيق السلم والاستقرار في
السودان ذلك يمثل مصلحه لليبي السيد عبد
الله
شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات